what we're going to do in this video is
take the function y is equal to the cube
root of x and then rotate this around
the x axis and if we do that we get a
solid of revolution that looks like that
and we're doing it between x is equal to
0 and x is equal to eight and you get
something that looks like this
and you could find the volume of this
actually quite easily using the disk
method but just to show you that you can
do it an alternate way we're gonna use
the shell method but we're gonna use the
shell method now to rotate around a
horizontal line and specifically the
x-axis so how would we do this well what
we want to do what you could imagine is
constructing rectangles
constructing a rectangle that looks like
this
let me do it in this salmon color so you
have a rectangle that looks something
like that its depth or its height you
could say is d y
and then its length right over here is
going to be 8 minus whatever x value
this is let me make this clear the
length
the the width
the width is going to be 8
8 minus whatever x value this is right
over here and you might already realize
that this is going to be d y we're going
to be integrating with respect to y over
an interval over an interval in y and so
we really want to have everything in
terms of y so this x value whatever it
is as a function of y so if y is equal
to the cube root of x we can cube both
sides and we could get x is equal to y
to the third power these are
equivalent statements right over here
and so this distance right over here is
going to be 8 minus
y to the third if we were to express it
in terms of y and then when you rotate
that thing around the x-axis it's going
to construct the outside of a cylinder
or a shell as we like to call it and
i'll try my best to draw that shell
so it will look something
like this
it will look something
like
so you're going to have a shell
you're going to have a shell that looks
that looks like this
and there you go and then actually this
shares a common boundary right over here
so you're going to have a shell that
looks something like that
so that hopefully helps a little bit let
me give it some depth
so the let me give it you'll have a
shell that looks something like that and
if we can figure out the volume of that
shell which is really going to be the
volume of the outer surface area times
or the area of the outer surface area
times the depth and then if we were to
sum up all of those shells this shell is
for a particular y in our interval if we
were to sum up over all of the wise
interval all of the shells all the
volumes of the shells then we have the
volume of this figure so once again how
do we figure out the volume of a shell
well we can figure out we can figure out
the circumference
of of kind of the top or i guess the
left or the right in this case the left
or the right of our cylinder if we can
figure out that circumference that
circumference circumference is equal to
pi
times the radius and what is the radius
the radius of these things are just
going to be your y value that's this
distance right over here that's just
going to be the y value so it's going to
be equal to 2 pi
times y
and then if we want the area of the
outer surface we just multiply that the
circumference times the width times the
width of our cylinder times the width of
our cylinder so let me write it over
here so outer surface area
outer surface
surface area
is going to be equal to our 2 pi y
2 pi y
times our 8 minus y to the third
8 minus y to the third eight minus y
third is just this length you multiply
that times circumference you get the
outer surface area
now if you want to find the volume of
this of this one shell it's going to be
the outer surface area 2 by y times 8
minus y to the third times the depth
times this d y right over here times the
d y i'll do the d y in purple times
the d y
times the d y so that's the volume of
one shell if we want to find the volume
of the entire
solid revolution we have to sum all of
these up and then take the limit as they
become infinitely thin and we have an
infinite number of these shells so we're
going to take the sum
from and remember we're dealing in y so
the volume the volume is going to be
equal to so what's our interval in terms
of y
so y definitely starts off at 0.
and when x is equal to 8 what is y
well x 8 to the 1 3 power is just 2. so
y is 2. this value right over here let
me make it a little bit clearer this
value right over here is 2. so y goes
from 0 to 2 and we've set up our
integral and this one looks pretty
straightforward so i think we can crank
through it in this video so this is
going to be equal to we can take out the
2 pi
2 pi times the definite integral from 0
to
of
let's multiply the y of 8 y
minus y to the fourth
all of that d y
all of that d y this is going to be
equal to 2 pi
times the antiderivative
of this business
antiderivative of 8y is 4y squared
4y squared anti-derivative of
one negative y to the fourth is negative
y to the fifth
over five and we're going to evaluate it
at zero and two
so this is going to be equal to
two pi
times you evaluate this business at 2.
2 squared is 4 times 4 is 16
minus
2 to the fifth 2 to the fifth is 32 so
minus 32 over 5 minus 32 over 5.
and then you evaluate the stuff at 0 you
just get 0. so that's what we're left
with and now we just have to simplify
this thing a little bit so let's see 16
over 5
this part right over here 16 over 5 is
the same thing as 80
or 16 is the same thing i should say is
80 over 5 and from that we're
subtracting 32 over 5.
so from that we're subtracting 32 over
5. and so that is equal to 48
over 5. so all of this business is equal
to 48 over 5. did i do that right 80
minus 30 is 50 and then minus another 2
gets us to 48. so this is 48 over 5
times 2 pi and now we deserve our drum
roll 48 times 2 is 96. we'll do this in
a new color just to emphasize that we're
at the end 48 times 2 is 96 times pi
over 5. so once again this is something
that you could have solved using the
disk method in terms of x and we're just
showing that you could also determine to
solve it in the shell method in terms of
wire the shell or the the hollowed out
cylinder method whatever you want to
call it in terms of y